this shiny metal is always in a liquid
state
it's much denser and heavier than water
and if you jumped into a pool full of
this stuff
you'd instantly regret it
the metal i'm talking about is liquid
mercury
yeah swimming in it would feel like
swimming in jello
only worse because it would burn and
seriously irritate your skin
and if you stayed in the pool long
enough
liquid mercury would get absorbed by
your skin and make it to your organs
even your brain
eventually it could cause speech
difficulties and lack of coordination
you could lose your vision too
and if you think this is bad well you
haven't seen the worst on our list yet
buckle up as we submerge you in the most
dangerous things
known to humanity
from painful stings
to severe frostbite this journey could
get fatal quick think you can make it
till the end
well for your next dangerous dive let me
take you to tanzania
here there's a lake so dangerous it
could turn you to stone
huh yeah that's right lake natron has
uncomfortably high ph levels
all thanks to being too close to an
active volcano
old diego lengai
this volcano spews out a rare kind of
lava rich in sodium and potassium
carbonate
and mix this stuff with water and you've
got yourself a mummification pool
after only five seconds in lake natron
you get third degree burns
that's because this lake can get as hot
as 60 degrees celsius
and don't swallow any of its water
because lake natron could burn your
insides
if you couldn't get out of this hot
water and stayed submerged long enough
your entire body would calcify and
harden
lake natron would preserve you so well
that even 100 years later
people could find your hair and what's
left of your organs intact
okay let's take it up a notch and throw
you into something even more dangerous
like a pool full of stingrays
these guys may look cute but don't let
them fool you
they're armed with long venomous
stingers ready to kill you at any moment
if you were stung by a stingray the
venom would flow into your bloodstream
and it would hurt
a lot
that's because of the serotonin in a
stingray's venom it would cause your
muscles to contract
badly
now imagine being stung by a pool full
of these creatures
not only would you feel as if your body
was twisting all around but you could
also experience a severe allergic
reaction
in that case you'd require proper
medical attention immediately
but luckily for you stingrays wouldn't
go after you unless they felt threatened
so just try not to disturb them and
you'll be fine
likely
most likely
probably
you know when it comes to swimming with
creatures you could do a lot worse
have you ever swam in a pool filled with
sharks
well you're about to give it a try
yeah sharks can smell your blood
they can also hear you very well
their hearing is on par with their
amazing sense of smell
but now if a shark took a bite out of
you
well it doesn't necessarily mean it
wanted to harm you
sharks are just extremely curious and
they use their teeth like you use your
hands
they investigate their surroundings by
touching things around them
with their teeth that's
weird and it really would be unlucky for
you to get stuck with a curious bunch of
sharks in one pool
but the chances are they wouldn't be
interested in you at all
sharks are wired to hunt fish and you'd
be a lot bigger than most sharks anyway
so they might be scared of you more than
you'd be scared of them
as long as you don't make any sudden
movements you could get out of that pool
unharmed
but i can't say that about the next item
on our list
volcanoes
active volcanoes are hot
i'm talking 500 degrees celsius hot
and as you stand on the rim of one you'd
be breathing in a ridiculously hot mix
of gases like sulfur and ammonia
that alone would cause you to pass out
but things are about to get
worse
as your unconscious body hit the magma
inside a volcano
the impact would be so hard that it
would break most of the bones in your
body
your skin would be flaming your lungs
would get seared but contrary to what
you might think
you wouldn't think
that's because magma can be thousands to
millions of times more viscous than
water
oh but there's one more thing
within seconds the intense temperature
inside of a volcano would make you go
poof
yeah you'd ignite into a ball of flames
and only your bones would be left
but not for long
okay i think it's time to cool off as
you prepare to take the number one most
dangerous dive on our list
a dive into a pool of liquid nitrogen
liquid nitrogen is non-flammable
it has no odor and no color
and it makes a ton of fun fog when you
expose it to room temperature air
so
why is it the most dangerous thing on
our list
well for starters liquid nitrogen would
displace oxygen around the pool
yeah you wouldn't be able to breathe and
might pass out before you have a chance
to feel anything else
but
that would be just the beginning
this stuff boils at a very low
temperature of minus 196 degrees celsius
so if you took a swim in a pool of
liquid nitrogen longer than a few
seconds
you wouldn't be coming back out
you would get severe frostbite all over
your body
your muscles fat and blood would be
frozen solid
if you managed to stay conscious and
kept your head above the surface your
body would freeze and sink right down
but there is some good news
since you would instantly turn into a
human popsicle you'd also experience
extreme nerve damage
meaning you simply wouldn't feel any
pain
you would just drown in a freezing cold
boiling nitrogen pool
and that's why it's number one on the
list of things you don't want to jump
into
but hey some journeys might be worth the
risk
like a jump in the deepest hole on earth
but that's a story
for another
what if